on select Sleep Number
360 smart beds. Only for a
limited time.
ask your doctor if BRILINTA
>> Martha: FLORIDA GOVERNOR,
URGING PEOPLE TO COMPLY WITH THE
CDC RECOMMENDATION TO KEEP
GATHERING UNDER TEN PEOPLE.
BUT DEMOCRATS SAY IT’S NOT
ENOUGH, DEMANDING TONIGHT THAT
HE "IMMEDIATELY CLOSE ALL ACCESS
TO THE PUBLIC BEACHES."
CORRESPONDENT, PHIL COME ALIVE
IN CLEARWATER BEACH, WHICH HAS
BEEN PRETTY CROWDED THIS WEEK.
HE IS THERE TONIGHT.
HI, PHIL.
>> HIGH MATT, MARTHA.
THE CITY OF MIAMI MAYOR WHO
TESTED POSITIVE FOR COVID-19
EARLIER THIS WEEK SAID FROM HIS
SEQUESTERED HOUSE, AND URGING OF
ALL THE CITY OF MIAMI RESIDENTS
TO SHELTER VOLUNTARILY.
THAT IS NEARLY 3 MILLION PEOPLE.
CLEARWATER BEACH HAS BEEN THE
SUBJECT OF NATIONAL SCOLDING AND
SHAMING.
FOR ALL THE FAMILIES AND SPRING
BREAKERS CROWDED ON THE BEACH,
BASICALLY IGNORING THE CDC
SOCIAL DISTANCING STANDARDS.
AS YOU SEE, THE SUNSET RIGHT
HERE ON THE GULF COAST, TAPPING
A GORGEOUS DAY ON THE BEACH.
ANOTHER DAY ON THE BEACH WITH A
WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE.
WE SAW PEOPLE ALL GATHERED
TOGETHER.
EVERYWHERE WE LOOK, THERE’S
ALWAYS A PROPER AMOUNT OF SPACE
AND DISTANCE BETWEEN BEACHGOERS,
AS IT IS SUPPOSED TO BE.
STATEWIDE, MOST OF THE BEACHES
DO REMAIN OPEN, ALTHOUGH MORE
ARE CLOSING EACH DAY.
EVERYONE IS SUPPOSED TO BE
SPACED OUT.
GROUPS SMALLER THAN TEN AND
6 FEET APART.
HERE’S WHAT CLEARWATER BEACH
LOOKED LIKE ON MONDAYS DESPITE
THE PANDEMIC THREAT.
CLEARWATER’S COUNCIL REACTED TO
THE CRITICISM ROLLING ALL
BEACHES WILL BE CLOSED STARTING
MONDAY.
BUT THAT CHANGED THIS AFTERNOON
AS THE COUNTY CLOSED ALL BEACHES
FOR WEEKS.
THAT BEGINS AT MIDNIGHT.
OVER IN COCOA BEACH, MORE
SPRING BREAK CROWDS PATCHED THE
BEACH WITH LITTLE CONCERN ABOUT
A VIRUS.
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE APPARENTLY
THINK IT ONLY SERIOUSLY AFFECTS
THE OLDER GENERATION.
>> FAMILY VACATION.
EVERYBODY IS FREAKING OUT OVER
THIS CORONAVIRUS.
IT’S A COLD.
WASH YOUR HANDS.
PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
MY WIFE IS A NURSE.
IT DOESN’T REALLY AFFECT US.
>> AND MILLENNIALS, WITH
IMMORTALITY DELUSION SHOULD NOTE
THIS.
BETWEEN THE AGES OF 20 AND 44,
20% END UP IN THE HOSPITAL.
THE CDC ALSO REPORTING THAT
NEARLY 40% OF ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
TEST POSITIVE FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS, THEY ARE ALL UNDER
THE AGE OF 55.
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF FLORIDA’S
DELEGATION URGING THE GOVERNOR
TO CLOSE ALL THE BEACHES FOR
GOOD.
RIGHT NOW, IT’S A BEACH TOWN
DECISION WHETHER OR NOT TO SHUT
THE BEACH.
>> Martha: ALL RIGHT.
GOOD FACTS.
IT CLEARLY DOES IMPACT PEOPLE
WHO ARE YOUNGER IN THAT AGE
20-50 AGE GROUP AS WELL.